tipp 1 nicht einfach bloß eine abstell
genehmigung erteilen das muss auch gut
durchdacht sein tatsächlich wirklich in
einem schuppen in der garage und nicht
einfach vor die tür legen ganz ganz
wichtig denn wir hatten sie auch in
dieser sendung wenn sie sagen der
paketbote darf das paket vor die tür
legen dann gilt das paket als zugestellt
und jeder kann sich bedienen
tipp 2 sprechen sie ihren zusteller
darauf an wenn er wirklich einfach das
paket vor die tür wirft oder stellt das
kann so einfach nicht sein da kann sich
wirklich jeder bedienen also dass es
wirklich reklamations grund tipp3
überprüfen sie sofort das paket auf
beschädigung und tatsächlich wurde das
schon mal geöffnet fehlender
möglicherweise gegenstände auch dann
sofort reklamieren dann tipp nehmen sie
nie ein beschädigtes paket für die
nachbarn an
denn der nachbar könnte sie für die
beschädigungen verantwortlich machen
obwohl sie es einfach nur nett gemeint
haben unter 5 wenn sie selbst
verschicken immer versichert verschicken
und nicht so viel sparen
sendungsverfolgung ist sehr sehr wichtig
es kommt wirklich sehr sehr viel weg